se mantuvo en lo más alto del ranking
mundial del tenis durante casi dos
décadas ahora después de luchar contra
una lesión de rodilla Roger Federer dijo
que la copa Label de la próxima semana
en Londres un torneo que él mismo creó
Será su último evento profesional
También conozco las capacidades y los
límites de mi cuerpo y su mensaje para
mí últimamente ha sido claro tengo 41
años he jugado más de 1.500 partidos en
24 años el tenis me ha tratado con más
generosidad de la que jamás hubiera
soñado y ahora debo reconocer cuando es
el momento de poner fin a mi carrera
competitiva Roger Federer tenía solo 19
años cuando venció a su ídolopit sampras
en la cancha de wimbledon en 2001 barrio
récord ganando el torneo 8 veces y se
ganó un lugar especial en su historia
Roger por dónde empezamos echaremos de
menos de presencia en nuestras canchas
pero todo lo que podemos decir por ahora
es gracias por los recuerdos y la
alegría que has dado tantos en total el
tenista suizo ganó 20 títulos de Grand
slam y pasó un récord de 237 semanas
consecutivas en el número uno de la ATP
llegó a compartir cada vez más
protagonismo con el serbio nueva
Djokovic y el español Rafael Nadal con
quien tiene una relación particular
querido Roger mi amigo y rival Ojalá
este día nunca hubiera llegado ha sido
un placer pero también un honor y un
privilegio compartir todos estos años
contigo aunque empezó siendo un jugador
revoltoso y propenso a decir malas
palabras Federer desarrolló una
reputación de deportista y de hombre de
familia Él y su mujer tienen dos pares
de gemelos que lo acompañaron durante
años en el Tour el anuncio del jugador
se produce justo después de La retirada
de Serena Williams por lo que el tenis
ha perdido a dos de sus más grandes esta
temporada